yeah my name's Rocky Balboa today I'm
going to be doing a review of rocky the
first one you know no more whack you I
back you with your brains you know what
you around human the whole [ __ ]
apartment you know go ahead give my
toilets in together be like here you
want some totals and then you know
they're gonna come right
it's okay Paulie come on rock do the
review this is stupid
today I'm gonna be reviewing rocky the
1970s one first off let me be straight
to the point here little callback for
fans
I love the Rocky movie I used to love
the franchise now every watched all them
I don't love the franchise anymore I
like a lot of the franchise but this
first one it's beautifully told it's
wonderfully acted now Sylvester Stallone
is not an amazing actor to me yet he
gives such an amazing performance in
this film in some ways it's kind of sad
re watching this film because you're
like wow this was our introduction
Estelle owned he was so good what the
[ __ ] happened yeah I just wanted to get
more buff and do more action you know
like somewhere down the line he began
getting just typecast as an action star
which totally sucks because Stallone
[ __ ] rocks at acting like if you
watch this rocky it's a total
3-dimensional performance now rocky is
his character who's like really down on
his luck you can tell rocky is a very
sincere dude but he masks the way he
feels he's like lonely depressed but he
keeps going to me it's one of the best
stories of success the big theme of this
movie is about going the distance you
know to keep getting back up and keep
moving forward like that song like I get
knocked down but I get up again you're
never gonna keep me down that's
essentially what the Rocky movies about
one thing that struck me as a bit odd is
that in the first half of this film
everyone treats Rocky like [ __ ] like
none of Philadelphia seems to like the
nicest guy in Philadelphia then again I
can sort of see how that works with the
film because halfway through the film is
when the real plot of the film takes
place an underdog boxer gets an
opportunity to take on the heavyweight
boxing champion in America Apollo the
Creed so I can see how when the world
hears about rocky and now he's famous
that they would all treat him with
respect but that kind of makes
Philadelphia look like a bunch of
douchebags growing up watching this
movie my favorite scenes were of course
like the boxing matches the the montage
sequences the training those one hand
push-ups I used to be able to do one
hand push-ups because I saw the first
rocky and
practice now I can do like five two-hand
push-ups now I haven't seen this movie
in a few years but watching it again I
actually found the first half of this
movie to be what I preferred that's not
saying the second half is bad at all
it's wonderful I just found my
preference to be the first in a weird
way it feels like you're hanging out
with Rocky you're like just story about
his everyday routine you really get a
vibe that you're there like observing
authenticity a real person they could
have called this the day in the life of
Rocky Balboa that spans several days
would have made sense
good call still oh yeah when you see
Sylvester Stallone as Rocky you don't
see Sylvester Stallone you just see
rocky Talia Shire as Adrian I loved her
performance her transformation in this
film has done so organically well I
sound like such a critic they're tense
so organically started from the
beginning of the film she's an extreme
case of introvert all she needed was a
good [ __ ] Bell Bogata entered the cave
right now you know so anyway yeah she's
practically a mute but then as a
romantic relationship ensues with her
and rocky you see little by little
subtle changes that start to happen or
her she starts coming out of her shell
more be more expressive starts to not
wear her glasses that's up that's a huge
huge step in maturity by the end she's a
totally different woman burgess Burgas I
don't know Meredith as Micky Burgess
fantastic performance by Mickey
I mean burgess the character of Mickey
is known to be a tough trainer he's he's
a dick he's just a dick like that is his
whole philosophy behind training is be a
douchebag there's this beautifully done
scene where Mickey wants to be Rocky's
manager now that rocky has the
opportunity to fight the champion at
this point we really don't like Mickey
the only scenes we've seen of him is him
just really being hard on rocky in not a
nice way at all but the but burgess is
married Mary
his white Meredith filled in for half of
the oh you such a lovely kid Rocky
shut up Meredith so yeah this one really
don't like rock blue [ __ ] we don't like
rocky happily so at this point we really
don't like Mickey it's kind of a dick
move on his part but there's a strong
level of vulnerability and subtlety done
in the right way from his performance
that gives you such a deep understanding
of the character is more vulnerable
sides more sympathetic side then it
makes sense why rocky ends up making the
decision on whether or not Mickey as his
manager or not what does he do what does
he do Burt young as Polly Polly is the
one character in all of the Rocky movies
or I'm like how the [ __ ] is he still
around he should have not been
associated with this family for a while
even in the first one I'm just like he
is abusive manipulative really just
treats domestic violence or Emin his
sister constantly he's like a threat to
your wife he wants to take advantage of
Rocky's success and he blames rocky for
when things aren't going what like it's
a well-written character but he's
definitely not likable that's one of my
criticisms starts the story is like
Polly is someone I'm just like he does
not seem like a person that is healthy
for your guy's life right now Carl
Weathers as Apollo the Creed I love this
performance too
at first it seems like he's it's just a
one note performance of this like
successful businessman slash boxer who's
like doing all the right business he
moves but his character transformation
actually takes place within the finale
match itself I can't give anything away
so I can't go into detail but pay
attention you'll see there's like a
character change that occurs just within
the fight and the last thing I'll say
the ending boxing match this movie has
that rare unique ability to truly make
you rue
for the underdog hero that one rocky
gets it it feels like you get hit that
when rocky lands a punch it feels like
you land a punch I do you gotta say
though rocky worst form of self-defense
I've ever seen from any fighter for like
four movies in a row that guy just Bob's
his head and it keeps his hands all the
way out here and just I'm like there's
no way he'll when the every Rocky match
pretty much goes there's no way he'll
win because he keeps getting hit so much
the only way he can win is by knockout
but but regardless of that fact when
you're watching the fight you really
feel every punch and it's it feels like
a real boxing match
Leigha Rocky is a classic and it's one
of my favorite sports movies of all time
my favorite Stallone performance the
best Rocky I've ever seen and
re-watching this has gotten me pretty
excited to go and check out Creed which
the review for it is coming anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to the channel if
you're new you can click this button
over here to subscribe become a reject
da key today reject a boba
waitwhat reject both there check the
Stallions reject a lien ah [ __ ] just
become a reject